[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEVE BAZYL: Hi, everyone.
And thanks for tuning in for
this week's "Google Developers
Live" for Google Drive.
Today we are joined by Mike
Borozdin from DocuSign, and
we're going to talk
about their app.
You'll get a quick demo,
talk about some of
the integration points.
There have been some really cool
stuff with Google Drive
and Apps Script, so a lot
of stuff to show.
We don't have any product
announcements this week, but
we are going to spend a lot of
time learning the ins and outs
of DocuSign, their APIs, and
talk about all the cool stuff
you can do.
So Mike, why don't you tell
people a little bit about
DocuSign, what you do, and
then give a quick demo.
MIKE BOROZDIN: Sure, sure.
Thank you.
So DocuSign is an electronic
signature service.
It basically allows people to
sign documents and contracts
without having to print them
out or use fax machines.
DocuSign's been around,
actually, for quite some time.
It's closing in on 10 years.
STEVE BAZYL: How long have
you been with DocuSign?
MIKE BOROZDIN: Actually,
a long time as well.
It's going to be seven
years next month.
So it's an eternity
in tech world.
But it's been great.
It's been great.
The company has been doubling
staff and the revenue, like,
every 12 to 18 months.
So always new challenges and
always exciting, and it's been
fantastic to see the
market adoptions.
STEVE BAZYL: And we've, I think,
been working together
for quite a while, actually.
I think the first integrations
you've had with Google Apps go
back probably two
or three years.
And they keep getting
better and better.
So why don't you give people
a quick look at some of the
things that you've been doing?
MIKE BOROZDIN: Sure.
So oftentimes, actually, even
though we have, like, 40
million users, I still see a lot
of people that have never
seen electronic signature.
So when I have a chance to
present our products, I always
start with signing.
A lot of people now when I talk
to them say, like, oh
yeah, sure.
I have used DocuSign with my
real estate transaction or
something along those lines.
But if you've never signed a
DocuSign document, I'm going
to show you this
on the screen.
You might get an email
invitation saying, like, hey,
there's some documents for
you to review and sign.
And there's a yellow button,
and you click it.
And it basically tells you Mr.
So and So, Ms. So and So
requested a signature.
You click that, and
you see here a
rendering of a document.
And if you've never signed
anything with DocuSign, what
you go through first
is adopting
your electronic signature.
And you can just select
a pre-defined one.
Or potentially you
can draw one.
But I'm not so good
at drawing it.
STEVE BAZYL: It's probably a
lot easier on a tablet or a
phone, or something like that.
MIKE BOROZDIN: Yeah, yeah.
There, a lot of people
really like it.
So once you actually adopt
your signature, from that
point on what you can
do is you can
apply it on a document.
So here you see I only
had one place to
sign, so I signed that.
And then I confirmed that
that was actually
my final step there.
And I'm done.
So on a very basic level, the
people that receive DocuSign
documents see that flow.
And as you can see, in 30
seconds or less they're able
to sign a document and return
it back to the sender.
But when it comes to the Google
integrations, which
we've been working and iterating
on and trying to
improve all the time and
continuously try to improve,
just this morning you gave me
some more pointers, I think
the most popular integration we
have is with Google Drive.
So this is where if you have a
document in Drive that you're
looking to send out to somebody
for a signature, you
can very quickly open
it with DocuSign.
And when you do that, DocuSign
integration will go in and
grab the document.
And then you can put the sticky
tabs in the places
where you want the signers
to sign or initial.
And we support all of the form
fields and regular expressions
and all of those conditional
validation stuff.
And then you go and basically
send it out and
then request a signature.
So once they sign it, it comes
right back to Drive,
where it came from.
STEVE BAZYL: So if you have a
library of prepared contracts
or templates for different
topics, then you just quickly
generate a new version design.
And do you actually save the
templates as well, where the
sticky tabs are?
MIKE BOROZDIN: Yeah.
There's a way for you to save
the templates or create new
ones, so for people, they
can save their workflow
themselves.
And oftentimes if it's a company
and if they have an
administrator, that
administrator can create
templates that just minimize the
errors and just streamline
the workflow for people.
So all of that stuff
is very possible.
Actions are important.
STEVE BAZYL: At Google I/O, you
showed off what I thought
was actually a really cool
demonstration of embedding the
document signature
functionality
right in Google Docs.
Can you talk a little bit about
that, and maybe show
what that's looking like?
I know it's not quite ready for
broad use yet, but I think
it's a good indicator of kind
of what the potentials are
going forward.
MIKE BOROZDIN: Yeah.
That's great.
So first of all, we
love our Google
partnership, first of all.
It's been great in many
different ways.
So any time there's something
on the horizon from Google,
another integration point or
another API, we always look
for ways to integrate
it into our product.
So Google Docs is one of
the most requested
features from our users.
Actually, Google Drive is our
number one document source.
So when people select
cloud-based document sources,
Google Drive is the top one.
So Google Docs, people
oftentimes edit a document,
they want to maybe add something
here or they want to
edit or delete a clause
or whatnot.
And again, who likes to go
through many, many steps to
just do a simple thing?
People prefer that everything
is integrated.
And here you can see there's
a DocuSign menu.
And when you click that
menu we've got a
side panel open up.
So this is all written
in Apps Script.
And the panel, the UI's popped
up, this is all integrated
with Google Docs.
It obviously has all
of the context.
This is the document you're
working on, who you are, how
to pair you up with the right
DocuSign account.
And in this express mode right
here, what you can do is you
can say, I'm going to send
this to somebody,
for example, Mike.
You fill this out and then
you send it out.
So it's all about just making
it super easy for people.
STEVE BAZYL: So you quickly
update the contract that you
want to send, and send that
out for a signature, and
shorten that process a lot.
You also have some
mobile apps.
The mobile app is really nice.
MIKE BOROZDIN: Thank you.
STEVE BAZYL: Earlier, we were
looking at this on a Nexus 7.
And it was a beautiful app, and
a really nice experience.
And you also have some other
integrations with Gmail as
well, right?
In terms of being able to sign
attachments and so on.
MIKE BOROZDIN: Right,
right, right.
Yeah, absolutely.
So Google Apps is another
popular integration of ours.
So folks that use Google
Enterprise applications like
Docs and Calendar and Gmail, can
go to the marketplace and
install Docu--
don't know about DocuSign yet,
but I can help them.
Right?
They send this.
And they said, hey, can you
sign this doc, please?
Well, again, there's an
easy button here.
I can go in and what happens in
the background is actually
we get the context
out of the email.
And we try to be smart
all the time.
We'll try and say, like, OK.
You've got your email addresses
there already,
you've got your documents
already, so let's do the best
we can to bring all of that
information together.
And it's probably the people
that you want to sign
documents with, so we bring
it into DocuSign.
And then you can lay out the
workflow here and either sign
yourself or request a signature
from somebody.
STEVE BAZYL: Very cool.
And actually, we were talking
earlier, and this is maybe one
of the areas where--
actually, could you
go back a screen?
Because there are a couple
things on here that we were
talking about earlier that I
think would be kind of useful
for developers to
take a look at.
So you also have the ability to
obviously pick from online
Cloud Storage, or choose an
online document, [INAUDIBLE]
files.
MIKE BOROZDIN: Yeah.
Let's try that again.
I think now that I've requested
it once, I probably
don't need to go through
that again.
But yeah, there was that
authorization screen.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah.
And so one of the things that
we covered here a few weeks
ago on our "GDLs" was, we've
actually covered this topic a
few times, the difficulty of
implementing file pickers,
particularly for
a large corpus.
If you're hitting a very large
enterprise with hundreds of
thousands of millions of
documents, it can actually get
very difficult and expensive to
build these types of UIs.
And also, just recently did
some research to find that
users actually don't like
when applications
access their full drive.
And actually, it's a pretty
significant drop off.
It's about 10% additional
drop off in acceptance.
Yeah, so there's a whole bunch
of different options in terms
of file pickers.
And I know Dropbox as well
has Filepicker widgets.
There's some third parties
in terms of--
Filepicker.io, which we
had on as a guest.
So for developers out there,
if you are in a situation
where you do have to implement
multiple cloud providers,
there are options rather than
having to build each one of
them yourself.
And some this you've been
working on for a while.
And some of these options
weren't always available.
MIKE BOROZDIN: Right.
STEVE BAZYL: So it's certainly
understandable.
But yeah, it's something that
you can probably simplify a
lot and just make this
a much faster--
MIKE BOROZDIN: It's a
nice way of saying
it's time for a refresh.
I get it.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah.
MIKE BOROZDIN: OK.
Yeah, no.
You're right.
STEVE BAZYL: It's just making
it simpler for users.
MIKE BOROZDIN: Absolutely.
STEVE BAZYL: I know you could
take advantage of our pickers
really fast.
You don't have to sit there and
fetch pages and pages of
documents and so on.
MIKE BOROZDIN: You know where
we do use your picker is in
our mobile app.
And there we see the difference
is tremendous.
So when you use our DocuSign
Ink product on an Android
tablet or your Google phone,
when you use the native picker
from Drive, that is a noticeable
difference.
You don't need to time it,
because it's so obvious.
So I don't know.
I assume you guys do some
caching of stuff.
STEVE BAZYL: Right.
In that case, you're calling
into the native Drive app, if
it's installed.
And that has all the
metadata cache.
And we can share that
information a lot faster.
MIKE BOROZDIN: Yeah,
super fast.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah.
The mobile app is beautiful.
So great job on that.
MIKE BOROZDIN: Thanks.
STEVE BAZYL: It's a great app.
I've surprisingly only recently
have started using
electronic signatures for all
the things I need to do.
And it's a hard habit to get
out of printing and signing
and scanning.
But it makes a huge, huge,
huge difference.
MIKE BOROZDIN: Thank you.
STEVE BAZYL: So one of the
things I also wanted to talk
about is you actually have
a set of APIs as well.
MIKE BOROZDIN: We do, yeah.
STEVE BAZYL: And since we have
a little bit of a similar
audience in terms of people
that work with documents,
especially people with Google
Apps, a lot of enterprise and
small business cases, anything
about your API, what you have
to offer that you think
would be interesting?
MIKE BOROZDIN: Absolutely.
So we actually put a lot
of effort into our API.
I think platform is sort of like
an abused term nowadays.
But I would say that when it
comes to DocuSign, I really,
truly believe that we are a
platform because about 50% of
all our transactions
come through API.
STEVE BAZYL: Oh, wow.
MIKE BOROZDIN: So 50% of our
business and our users don't
use our web interface directly,
they use us from
applications like Drive and
third party integrations.
So we put a lot of emphasis on
making it easy for developers
to get going with electronic
signatures.
So if you're taking notes,
docusign.com/devcenter or
developer-center, either one,
is a special part of our
website that's dedicated
to developers.
And you can get a free
development account and get a
sandbox and start kicking
the tires.
Because we know that developers,
they want to see
stuff work immediately.
So the faster you can get down
to a working script or a
working program, the more
successful you're going to be.
And we've got code samples in
five different languages, and
an interactive way to
exercise our APIs.
And it generates JSON for you.
And yeah, it's been great.
First of all, we love working
with developers because the
type of genius that
you come across--
sometimes you're like, wow.
You did that?
That is amazing.
And just working with
smart people is
always, always a pleasure.
STEVE BAZYL: And you
occasionally host meet-ups and
everything at your offices
in San Francisco.
MIKE BOROZDIN: Yeah.
STEVE BAZYL: You have other
offices as well, right?
MIKE BOROZDIN: Yeah.
STEVE BAZYL: I think you're
up in Washington.
MIKE BOROZDIN: Seattle,
Washington
we have a big office.
We have a big office
here, right in
downtown San Francisco.
And we try to be engaged in
the developer community.
And we also try to sort of give
back to the community by
hosting meet-ups at least a
couple of times a month and
just providing people with
resources and doing hack
nights and whatnot.
STEVE BAZYL: Very cool.
MIKE BOROZDIN: It's really
fun, actually.
It's really fun for
us as well.
STEVE BAZYL: And one
last question.
I know you mentioned earlier,
Drive was your primary source,
or at least largest source, of
cloud storage documents.
We were chatting a little bit
earlier about the Chrome Web
Store and some of the
leads that you're
generating from that.
And I imagine for a company
that's largely come from the
enterprise space and more
traditional sales cycle, it's
a nice addition to bring in some
of these online sales and
different types of leads than
what you would normally get
through your sales force.
MIKE BOROZDIN: Sure.
So both Drive and Google Apps
are fantastic in terms of a
channel for us.
And this is all public
information, you can go to
Chrome Web Store and you can
see that we have close to
80,000 people that have
signed up for DocuSign
through that channel.
And this is all, like with
a lot of things that are
associated with Google, once you
figure out how to properly
use the tools, you're kind of
riding the Google wave.
And it's fantastic.
So Google Apps is another great
channel where that's
more geared towards the
enterprises and corporate
businesses.
And we get a lot of
leads from that.
And that's been great as well.
And of course, being featured
on the Android store--
STEVE BAZYL: Oh, nice.
Yeah.
MIKE BOROZDIN: --the
Google Play store.
Yeah, that helped a bunch
as well, so thank you.
Like I said, we just love
our partnership here.
And to many more years.
STEVE BAZYL: Very cool.
I know you need to get back
up into the city--
MIKE BOROZDIN: Yeah,
thank you.
STEVE BAZYL: --for some
meetings up there.
So but yeah, this
has been great.
Thanks for the demos
and the insights.
Next week, we will be here
with floreysoft.
So Daniel Florey, the founder
of that company, will be
joining us remotely.
And he's going to talk about
some of the new apps that
they've been building, Editey
as well as Ultradox and some
other cool stuff.
And yeah, we'll be
back next week.
Again, Mike, thanks for coming
and taking some time out of
your schedule.
MIKE BOROZDIN: Thank
you, yeah.
STEVE BAZYL: And we'll see
everyone next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]